it's great to be joined today by Maurice
Carney who is the co-founder and
executive director of friends of the
Congo and advocacy institution raising
consciousness about the situation in the
Congo also providing support to local
institutions particularly youth Maurice
it's so great to speak to you know we
are at the 20th anniversary of soldiers
entering Congo this is a conflict that
maybe is is not a particularly familiar
to many in our audience so let's start
with 1996 what happened in 96 and talked
to us about the wholesale devastation
that we've seen since then sure in 1996
the Rwandan and Ugandan government along
with Angola Grundy invaded the Congo and
we use the term invasion because they
were not invited in they went into the
Congo ostensibly in pursuit of
perpetrators of the genocide in Rwanda
would cross into Congo's border and
unfortunately however they they went
further than that they did not just
pursue these perpetrators however they
also overthrew the government at the
time underarm Joseph Desiree Mobutu the
country was called as a year then and
installed the leader of the rebel
movement that they had used the Rwanda
and Uganda Jews used as a proxy his name
was Lauren Desiree Camilla and he was
ultimately installed in may of nineteen
ninety-seven the warden and Ugandan
faction I fell out with mr. kabila in
1998 and they invaded a Congo a second
time in 1998 those two invasions
combined triggered what the United
Nations says the deadliest conflict in
the world since world war two were an
estimated six million people lost their
lives between 1996 and 2007 2007 the
last date for
any mortality study in the country I was
due to the to the conflict so you have a
situation where not only the the Rwandan
you got in particular invade the DRC
they also supported militia groups
inside the country even after the
official end of the war the war ended in
2002 however as a result of the
instability in the east of the country
the conflict is ongoing and the current
president joseph kabila is the product
of this 20-year conflict because he came
in to office as a result of being a part
of that invading force that the rebel
group that had moved across the country
his father laurent kabila was initially
installed was assassinated in 2001 and
Joseph took over formed from his father
presided over a transition process that
lasted until two thousand six when
elections were held and Joseph Kabila
was elected president and according to
the constitution which was ratified in
2006 president can hold two to five year
to conserve four to five-year terms so
president commuter served from 2006 to
2011 and then he won elections again in
2011 even though those elections were
riddled with fraud and he basically
stole the 2011 election so colonies
people were like okay fine you in 10
power 4 to 2 terms your term X to your
second term expires in 2016 however now
that we're in 2016 Joseph Kabila does
not want to leave power he was he
supposed to leave office on December
nineteenth this year and supposed to be
replaced by an incoming president
however his administration I basically
refused really to organize elections so
that he wouldn't have a replacement and
due to the fact that mr.
you has control over the courts he got a
constitutional court to rule incredibly
that mr. kim bo doesn't have to leave
office until he's replaced by incoming
president so if you don't organize
elections uh you can't be replaced by an
incoming president so yeah conceivably
he could rule forever so you see how
preposterous that is yeah and I I'm
curious Maurice meet you you've outlined
you started with telling us about it you
know the the the millions of fatalities
that have resulted from the conflict
you've talked to us about at least some
of the points that have contributed to
not having a peaceful transition of
power since independence was one in 1960
what's your sense of why this conflict
is not as present in the minds of many
in the West as other conflicts and this
is something I find fascinating but also
disturbing which is the way and which
certain conflicts are regular Western
news and on the forefront of many minds
in America and Western Europe etc and
other conflicts and clearly this is a
conflict where the numbers in the data
tell us this is outrageous does not make
news in the same way what's your sense
of it it's not any one reason there it's
a it's a complex of interlocking reasons
right I'd say one the interests that are
at stake for example US has been
involved in the Congo since day one
since its independence right the Congo
is the first post-independence country
that the United States intervened in
post independent African country and it
was the united states that honor the CIA
to overthrew Congo's first
democratically elected prime minister
patrice lumumba which the chief of
station of the CIA that time Larry
Devlin outlines in a book or the same
title of Congo chief of station then the
US installed Joseph Mobutu's a dictator
for over three decades I'm so the US has
been on
wrong side of the issue in the Congo
even the invasions in 96 98 the u.s.
provided backing for Rwanda and Uganda
and those are those invasions so US
interests has played a destructive role
in the Congo so it's not like Dar for
for example where you can point the
figure to the Chinese who involved
economically and to the Muslims or to
the Islamic religion so those were the
bogeyman but in this case in terms of a
negative role its US government US
corporations that have played a negative
role so that would tamp down on the
coverage that's what we reasoned that
that would you know the CNN and CBS
wouldn't be so quick to say well here it
is that you have to do this conflict in
the world since World War two and by the
way those countries that invaded the
Congo the United States Armed them
finance them train them provided them
with intelligence oh and also when
international bodies like the United
Nations try to hold these perpetrators
accountable the US has run diplomatic
and political interference and there's
actually more easy isn't there also
another layer of u.s. involvement which
is that President Joseph Kabila himself
hired a DC lobbying firm called the BG I
group for just under a million dollars
that lobbying group was founded by
former Republican governor of
Mississippi haley barbour uh and and I
mean we're talking about lobbying
interests involved in the Congo as well
oh yeah absolutely that that's a later
occurrence but that that's a classic
example of where you have an African
government that are committing crimes
locally because the kabila regime is
firing up on nonviolent produce a
demonstrator Xin killing them in from
January 2015 they killed at least four
dozen or around four dozen protesters
just this year September
19th and 20th according to United
Nations that killed over 50 so these
crimes are being committed locally
they're being cleansed on the
international level and a lobbying firms
such as B G our group was one of those
institutions that are being tasked by
the Congolese government hired by the
Congolese government to clean up its
image in the international community so
that does play a role so that's that's
one reason us- us in engagement a second
reason for lack of attention is we
talking about Africa especially the
Congo you know Joseph Conrad's classic
work heart of darkness that's still in
the mind and the psyche of people that
we're talking about this dark continent
so that's what happens there you know
people die there so it doesn't raise
rise up on on the meter and those lives
are less valued so it doesn't you know
call for as much attention as much focus
a much investigation as much inquiry so
that's the second reason the third is
the nature of the conflict is that
conflict is a slow-moving conflict right
where the overwhelming majority of
people have lost your lives of lost your
lives as a result of displacement being
driven into the forest village is being
destabilized people dying from pneumonia
and exposure so that also makes a
difference in terms of it's not dramatic
you know bombs dropping yeah being fired
upon consistently so that and that adds
to the complexity of the conflict so
those reasons those are some of the
reasons I believe that it's not it
doesn't get as much it doesn't get as
much attention and again i really want
to reinforce this point it's when when
when conflicts happen on the African
content for the most part they usually
attributed to ethnic or tribal conflict
night up there's the political and
geopolitical elements of those conflicts
are drained out and people look at the
situation as if it's with resignation
that that's always happen enough in this
we're going to continue to have happen
in Africa so we're introducing a new way
of looking at
of the continent and showing all the
players that are involved the Europeans
the Asians the Canadians the Americans
you know the United Nations publishes
several studies in two thousand from
2001 to 2003 where they documented some
85 corporations that meant was involved
in the Congo and contributed to
perpetuating the conflict so it is
everybody really wants a piece of the
Congo foreign government multilateral
institutions such as the International
Monetary Fund in the World Bank
corporations you know you have felt
Dodge or what is not free point lemoore
and here in Arizona that's involved on
copper and cobalt you have the olean
group that's out of Cleveland or near
ohio that's involved in mining of copper
and cobalt there just a whole range of
corporations that have been involved in
the in the cargo no doubt and that gets
to the conversation about conflict
minerals that end up in the mobile
phones and and other electronics here in
the United States but a conversation for
a different day we've been speaking with
these Carney co-founder and executive
director of friends of the Congo thanks
so much for joining me in talking about
this all right thank you